the highest level diplomatic visit to
ukraine since the war began
the president of the european commission
ursula wonderland joined by the bloc's
foreign policy chief joseph borle first
visited the town of buchar the city
northwest of kiev has drawn
international attention since the
evidence emerged of mass atrocities
allegedly committed by russian forces
it's an allegation that russia denies
wonderland appeared visibly shocked when
she saw the exhumed bodies of those
found in mass graves
here in butcher we saw our humanity
being shattered
and
it is
the whole world is mourning with the
people of bucha
madam president
you're welcome
in kiev the eu delegation was welcomed
by ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
at the presidential palace where they
discussed a variety of outstanding
issues from the construction of the
war-torn country to the supply of new
weapons
at the press conference afterward both
promises were made chief among them
ukrainian membership of the eu
it will be not as usual a matter of
years to form this opinion but i think a
matter of weeks if we work closely
together for you
welcomed the promises and offer of a
fast-track membership
but hinted too at this unity in the
union over the severity of sanctions
placed on russia
the most important thing now is to be
united
be together
even when leaders of certain countries
are slowing down or breaking this
process
at the brink of war the capital kiev saw
an exodus of diplomatic missions
now as european leaders re-emphasize
their support for ukraine joseph bortle
told me diplomats will be staying
that the delegation of the european
union my delegation the delegation of
the foreign affairs
is coming it's coming with us
accompanying us company president
vanderlian and myself and they will
remain here and delegation will be
reopened
as kiev reconnects with the world those
killed here are
remembered ukraine's war with its
eastern neighbor appears to be pushing
it closer to its european allies in the
west
al jazeera